vamos a hablar un poco acerca de la
regulación del adn y es esta idea
general de que si nos fijamos en el
genoma de un organismo no todos los
genes están siendo transcrito si
traducidos al mismo tiempo en realidad
podría depender del tipo de célula que
está conteniendo al adn o podría
depender del entorno en el que se
encuentra ese organismo por ejemplo si
nos fijamos en un organismo multicelular
y esta es una simplificación excesiva
pero digamos que esta es una célula del
sistema inmune
inmunes
y digamos que estaré aquí es una célula
muscular y no necesariamente tienen
estas formas circulares pero es solo
para darnos una idea y ambas van a tener
exactamente el mismo adn así que el adn
en ambas es el mismo y como son células
eucariotas voy a dibujar aquí y sus
membranas nucleares ambas células
desempeñan funciones muy diferentes en
el interior del organismo incluso para
que tengan estructuras diferentes van a
tener que producir proteínas diferentes
van a tener diferentes enzimas dentro de
su citoplasma y así la regulación del
adn una manera de pensar en ella es si
tienen exactamente el mismo genoma cómo
se regula cuáles quienes están siendo
transcrito si traducidos y cuáles no e
incluso si pensamos en un organismo
unicelular aquí tenemos una bacteria y
es solo una célula pero incluso esta
célula no va a querer transcribir y
traducir todos sus genes al mismo tiempo
por ejemplo aquí tenemos el cromosoma ba
y este de aquí podría ser un gen
implicado en la digestión de un cierto
tipo de alimentos si ese alimento está
presente y de hecho incluso podrían ser
varios los genes que están involucrados
en esta función y vamos a hablar más
adelante acerca de cuando se tienen
varios genes que están relacionados
entre sí y tienden a ser transcritos
todos a la vez o tienden a no ser
transcrito todos a la vez tal vez está
relacionado con digerir o consumir algún
tipo de alimento tal vez hay unos genes
por aquí que están relacionados con
algún tipo de mecanismo de estrés tal
vez tiene que entrar en hibernación por
un tiempo y así si no está bajo estrés
no tiene que expresar estos genes pero
en caso de que se encuentra bajo estrés
si tiene que expresarlos del mismo modo
si consumió el tipo de alimento que
requiere de estos genes para digerirlo
entonces necesita transcribir estos
genes pero si no consumió ese alimento
entonces no necesita transcribir estos
genes así es como funciona la regulación
de adn
ya sea que se esté hablando de una
célula eucariota o una célula
procariotas y así lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es enfocarnos en cómo
ocurre esto en las células procariotas
sobre todo vamos a hablar acerca de esta
bacteria cuando hablamos de la
transcripción en general y esto lo vimos
hace varios vídeos y tocamos este tema
en varios vídeos hablamos sobre la idea
de un promotor dijimos que tenemos un
gen que es una secuencia de adn que es
parte del cromosoma y dijimos que la arn
polimerasa se necesita unir al gen en
algún lugar de manera que la arn
polimerasa se tiene que unir en algún
lugar y llamamos a ese lugar en el que
la arn polimerasa se une al gen lo
llamamos promotor y así la polimerasa
puede transcribir el gen y cuando
hablamos por primera vez de la idea de
un promotor dijimos que y esto es
generalmente cierto en las células
eucariotas dijimos que cada promotor
está asociado a un gen
que cada gen tiene un promotor pero
cuando estamos hablando de células
procariotas y en este caso estamos
hablando de esta bacteria es común tener
múltiples genes agrupados que tienen un
promotor y un promotor también es
llamado secuencia reguladora de adn
permíteme escribir eso por lo que el
promotor que es esta parte justo aquí
está secuencia es una secuencia
reguladora de adn
secuencia
reguladora
t
a de n bueno eso es a lo que la arn
polimerasa se une la arn polimerasa es
esta bola que dibujé por aquí y luego
comenzará a transcribir todos estos
genes como un paquete y cuando se tiene
un promotor asociado a múltiples genes
la combinación del promotor y los genes
y una vez más cuando estoy hablando de
promotores de los genes estoy hablando
de secuencias de adn a esa combinación
se les llama operón esto se llama operón
es la combinación de esa secuencia
reguladora de adn que dice oye arn
polimerasa únete aquí para que puedas
comenzar la transcripción y los genes
para los que promueve la transcripción y
luego por supuesto inicia el proceso de
transcripción la arn polimerasa toda la
información genética en el adn la
transcribe a arn mensajero y después el
arn mensajero va a los ribosomas y ahí
se da todo el proceso de traducción
en el cual se producen las proteínas que
tienen funciones dentro de e incluso
potencialmente fuera de la célula y esto
es sólo un repaso de transcripción y
traducción y lo que vamos a ver más a
fondo es que puede mejorar este proceso
hacer que ocurra con más frecuencia o
qué cosas pueden inhibir este proceso de
alguna manera así que como he mencionado
antes esto es lo que acabo de dibujar
tenemos la arn polimerasa y esto es una
simplificación excesiva de como
realmente es unida a la secuencia
reguladora de adn a la que llamamos
promotor y luego hará la transcripción
que producirá a efe nm que codifica la
información contenida en esos genes pero
qué pasa si estamos en un ambiente en el
que no queremos transcribir este o
perdón en particular está secuencia de
genes en particular bueno algo en
nuestro entorno podría permitir que
represores entren en acción y que es un
represor bueno un represor lo vemos
unido
a una secuencia de adn después del
promotor por lo que bloquea a la arn
polimerasa de manera que ya no puede
hacer la transcripción así que esta de
aquí es una proteína que se llama
represor que está literalmente
reprimiendo la transcripción y la
secuencia reguladora de adn a la que se
une se llama operador así que una vez
más el promotor es una secuencia
reguladora que se puede unir a la arn
polimerasa y luego el operador es una
secuencia reguladora donde un represor
se puede unir y así evitar que la arn
polimerasa puedan llevar a cabo la
transcripción
y también podemos tener mecanismos
adicionales e incluso se puede pensar en
ellos como mecanismos de
retroalimentación o maneras de entender
el medio ambiente donde el represor esta
proteína vamos a decir que este es el
represor que solo puede hacer su trabajo
si tiene otras moléculas unidas a él así
que este tal vez solo puede ser su
trabajo si tiene otra molécula unidad
por aquí y en ese caso a estas moléculas
más pequeñas se les llama con represores
go red pre short
y vamos a entrar en más detalle cuando
hablemos de cosas como el operante erp
de como el triptófano un aminoácido
puede actuar como un corre preso ahora
por acá tenemos la otra situación en la
que queremos aumentar o acelerar la
transcripción y en ese caso tendríamos
algo llamado activador y este adn por
aquí esta sería la secuencia reguladora
donde el activador se une por lo que
ésta sería retroalimentación positiva
cuando se tienen más activadores vamos a
aumentar la transcripción y en realidad
no debería llamarlo retroalimentación
porque eso implica que de alguna manera
estos productos producen al activador o
que estos productos producen al represor
pero ese no es necesariamente el caso
podría ser podríamos imaginarnos ese
caso pero no es necesariamente el caso
solo debería decir que éste está
reprimiendo y éste está activando va a
hacer que aumente la transcripción y del
mismo modo en que podemos tener con
represores moléculas pequeñas en las que
podríamos pensar como que están
accionando al represor también podemos
tener pequeñas moléculas que pueden
encender al activador y estas pequeñas
moléculas que encienden el activador son
llamadas inductores por lo que estos de
aquí son inductores así que esta
proteína no puede activar al operón pero
ahora que tenemos a estos inductores y
más adelante vamos a estudiar un poco
más al operón lac
esto podría ser una pequeña molécula de
algún tipo de azúcar que puede encender
la activación
por lo que está de aquí se llama
inductor
así que esto fue solo una descripción
general de la regulación del adn como te
puedes imaginar esto puede llegar a ser
muy muy interesante y complejo donde
tenemos a los represores a los correo
profesores y a los activadores e
inductores que podrían depender del
entorno en que la célula se encuentre lo
que está pasando en su ecosistema hay
todo tipo de asas de retro y pre
alimentación que podrían estar
sucediendo y se pueden tener la
secuencia de hecho es posible secuenciar
genomas enteros pero incluso una vez que
se tiene la secuencia es increíblemente
complejo entender todas estas asas de
retro y pre alimentación y entender cómo
interactúa todo esto en conjunto